have you seen the the protests in places
like melbourne
and and oh for the lockdown and nobody's
reporting on it do you
it's the biggest
million you can imagine yeah melbourne
and why is the australian yeah england
really because they want people to think
everybody's cool with it we're not we're
sick of it
people get nuts man that is [ __ ]
crazy yeah it's nuts i mean cheese and
it's just
melbourne right
no dude it's all over it's all over the
line i mean america not so much but no
no i'm talking about just melbourne like
as far as australia no australia new
zealand's bad with their lockdowns they
have curfew and then uh uh [ __ ] uh
it's just too much ireland has protests
why'd you bring up tim kennedy uh he
posted something about it oh there you
go some of the largest protests in
history happening in rome france
melbourne all over the world you don't
see them for a reason yeah
yeah look at that and they don't report
any of it because they don't want people
to think i mean some of this might be
anti-vaxxed stuff which you know
as opposed to it's not antibiotics it's
locked down okay anti right right yeah
don't don't spread that that's anthony
no i i thought that's what it was but no
it's i'm sure there's some of it but
really it's them you know getting
want to go to work they want to live
their life
it's like stop with this the don't act
like this is killing uh more than one
percent not even that anymore
you're you're you're you're spreading
misinformation it's wow
i mean i remember there was one point in
time i knew so many people that had
coveted right now i don't know anyone
that has covet
i don't know well with that new version
my buddy jimmy burke
they're trying to scare everybody with
you know i have a friend who's on the on
the board the cdc and today during the
california meeting they're like
we don't get where all the news is
getting like it's no more dangerous than
the original and it also has really mild
effects
the head of the the health organization
in africa south africa the lady came out
she goes
yeah we've it's here off the australian
hair she goes i'm it's more mild than
the original she's like i don't get like
talk about that
yeah yes
the stock market took a huge crash uh
jimmy burke got it he was on his way to
see his mother who's 88 or you cannot
have covert she would die yeah and and
uh five minutes before that his
girlfriend said i just tested positive
he goes oh [ __ ] they his friend turns
her around there are 12 people waiting
for him he doesn't get tested he's
positive
he was like i'm a little chill but he
had the vaccination he goes i'm little
chills but i could play tennis right now
like he's yeah yeah i'm totally fine
totally fine breathes right through it i
mean he got vaccinated so apparently
when you get vaccinated it helps you if
you if you catch covet even then yeah
but his girlfriend had the booster as
well and she got it yeah and but she's
okay she's fine yeah it's not it's not
bad but i i'm surprised hopefully when
that pill comes out which is gonna
just annihilate everything when that
comes out
covets hey listen it's over hey you're
not going to die from covert we just got
to live you guys
live with you with a heart transplant or
if you have you know underlying
conditions yeah yeah some crazy flu
though i mean yeah you get the flu and
you have unlike health conditions
yeah so so so we've done a great job yes
it's over though combating covet with
vaccines with therapeutics
and i i just i i watch i was on the
plane and i watched these this couple
and they're just they're wiping down
everything they're wiping down
everything they they just ate a noise
you're still on a plane with a bunch of
people but a little adversity you just
shows the true colors a bit a little
adversity you realize you're surrounded
by a bunch of [ __ ] can you imagine if
we get it if we if a virus
kills 15 percent of us no i'm locked i
mean of course yeah of course but i'm
saying can you imagine i'll be the guy
wiping down the plane but it shows you
what could happen to a society that's
working it just shows you how soft
society is you got to be ready you got